turn now to global affairs and some
looming crises that could unfold over
the next 10 years they are outlined in
the new book the power of crisis and how
three threats and our response will
change the world it's published by simon
schuster a division of cbs's parent
company that would be paramount global
author is ian bremmer he is the founder
and president of the eurasia group and g
zero media uh and ian joins us now uh
ian thank you for being here good
morning uh you you narrowed it down to
three crises but it seems like there's a
new one every day and the one we're
dealing with right now in buffalo is
white supremacy which you say is a
bigger threat than radical islam in this
country why and by the way our
government agrees the government agrees
uh why is the public doesn't agree with
that though they still see it
differently some in the public don't
agree yeah i mean why is it so hard
first of all to get agreement on that
question and also to stop it
why it's so hard is because it doesn't
seem to be a really urgent problem for
the average american because most of the
people that's hitting are seriously
disenfranchised i mean sort of reminds
me of crack cocaine as a crisis back in
the 80s and 90s i mean we all knew it
was a big deal but it was inner city and
did the people that were in power really
care was the response going to be
performative it's performative
the global hunger crisis right now is
another one of those it feels to me like
climate did 20 30 years ago before it
started hitting everyone right remember
i mean we all knew the science on
climate but we weren't going to do
anything about it until started hitting
california and italy and australia and
now
we are responding we truly are that the
part of the book is about when the
crisis gets big enough your capacity to
make a real difference and even when the
u.s is still dysfunctional even when the
u.s china relationship isn't so good you
actually see that traction and it's
playing out right now but i like how you
say they're on page 22 early in the book
no sources of outrage more deeply
embedded in american life than
structural racism and determined efforts
of some to pretend it does not exist to
paraphrase william faulkner
institutional racism isn't dead it isn't
even passed it doesn't pass that's what
i'm saying i think a lot of people don't
realize i know all the politicians say
it all the elected officials the fbi
directors have said it both of them uh
comey and christopher wray but the
american people i don't feel still
understand how serious this problem is i
mean gail when this when when you guys
started yesterday in response to buffalo
and i saw you i'm tired of being angry
yeah and i how do you not feel that
after decades and decades and decades
not like jim crow was just around the
corner i mean we elected obama did it
make a difference the fact is the united
states today is the most politically
divided and dysfunctional of the
advanced industrial democracies the
dollar is really strong people want to
come to our country still we've got this
great technology our military certainly
works we see all of that and yet
washington is so divided that we can't
get the obvious done but the funny thing
is that my book ultimately ends up still
very hopeful because it says even if we
can't fix that right that we still see
that a target-rich crisis environment
that we're in today is not about curling
up in a ball and waiting for the
inevitable it's precisely that those
crises force us into action and frankly
the headlines that we've seen for the
last two months on russia i wish putin
had read an earlier draft of the book
because he didn't think we could respond
right and it turns out we can you
mentioned the word
divided and speaking of division social
media comes to mind as as good of a
vehicle it can be for information
sometimes it can create and exacerbate
some of these issues that we have in
this country
and speaking of social media the
misinformation and polarization is a
threat on our democracy like you said
why so look when
20 years ago more a little more than i
got my phd
technology actually was it helped
democracies it hurt authoritarian states
remember that that cartoon a dog's on
the computer yeah because on the
internet no one even knows if your dog
so you had all these anonymous people
that are on there getting information
they're learning more about their
societies and they will bring it down if
you don't fix it which is how the wall
came down it's how we got the colored
revolutions it's how we got the arab
spring today if you're on the internet
we know if your dog we know exactly what
kind of dog you are we have all that
data it's the data revolution the
surveillance revolution that empowers a
country like china that's able to
surveil and lock down their populations
and it doesn't empower a country like
the united states it actually drives
more extremism and polarization and you
think that's the most dangerous crisis
we face on the planet i think the
inability to understand and contain
disruptive technologies whether it's the
artificial intelligence that's being
pumped into our bloodstream and our kids
or whether it's cyber attacks and
offensive capabilities it's
disinformation it's lethal autonomous
drones it's even quantum computing when
we had nuclear weapons we said we've got
to contain that right it's too dangerous
and over 75 years we've done a pretty
good job yeah these technologies we're
not even starting to address them i
think that's the most dangerous question
so quickly bremer thank you very much
this book is the power of crisis and
it's on sale today wherever you buy your
books